salut à toi jeune entrepreneur savais-tu
que lorsque Emmanuel va au McDo il ne
commande pas un Macron mais bien un
McKinsey alors pose-toi les bonnes
questions
est-ce que tu préfères continuer à faire
le Pen et endetté comme Valérie avec 5
millions ou comment c'est très
rapidement à faire de l'argent avec moi
pour pouvoir commencer une carrière dans
l'humour avec Éric Zemmour moi je pose
la question elle est vite répondu alors
soit tu me suis
soit tu votes pour Jean-Luc car nous ne
mélangons pas les serviettes et les
torchons bisous
suis-moi et passe de fromage président à
renoi président
mais je pense qu'elle est très en colère
là ouais je suis très en colère pourquoi
parce que si il avait pas se passer avec
l'extrême droite
Zemmour Le Pen etc peut-être qu'on
aurait pu noter la touche d'humour le
travail de au niveau du texte etc mais
là moi ce que je vois c'est un noir avec
un blanc un blanc qui explique un noir
que s'il veut devenir riche il faut
qu'il soit comme lui et derrière toutes
les caricatures qu'on puisse imaginer
sur les gens de la cité tout ce qui peut
se dire etc armée capuché qui bouscule
et en gros s'il veut de si veut rouler
dans ce type de voiture il doit agir
comme le blanc et je trouve ça horrible
et je vois pas et c'est pas du tout
pardon c'est du coupé-décalé en tant que
alors la question est posée est-ce que
est-ce que c'est pas une grande
mascarade totalement c'est ridicule il
avait une certaine quoi qu'on en pense
au delà des idées il avait une certaine
crédibilité politique et il voulait en
faire son avenir comme ça n'a pas marché
qu'il est un peu rejeté de partout qu'il
est perdu il tente maintenant de
s'associer avec cette personne vous
savez c'est l'influenceur qui promet
d'être riche il voulait chef
d'entreprise venez avec moi je vais vous
montrer comment être riche rapidement
donc je trouve ça indigne de Tanguy
David et là pour le coup on ne sait plus
du tout il va il va foncer dans le mur
Guillaume ce que je peux vous dire c'est
qu'il est complètement grillé en
politique souverain vous au début de la
campagne il était présenté comme soutien
officiel d'Éric Zemmour et peu à peu ont
la plus vue sur les plateaux parce que
les équipes de reconquête se sont
détachées de lui le soupçonnant d'être
un énorme fake d'être un énorme troll
qui est en fait là juste pour faire le
buzz et d'ailleurs là il se décrédient
complètement parce qu'il a passé son
temps à dire qu'il ne voulait pas qu'on
le réduise à sa couleur de peau là il
enchaîne les clichés les stéréotypes
donc c'est terrible pour lui et je pense
qu'il fait partie de ces jeunes qui sont
prêts à tout pour faire du buzz à tout
pour qu'on parle d'eux et il est
complètement gris en politique
d'ailleurs on l'a vu que ça fait
refouler est-ce que ça remet en cause
les vidéos où il était agressé on se
pose des questions mais évidemment ah
oui mais complètement
pour moi ce genre de personnage quand on
se met en scène comme ça dans une vidéo
qui est pas drôle c'est lourd il y a
rien de positif en fait ça n'apporte
rien
du négatif effectivement ça casse enfin
ça salit l'image de plein de choses il y
a des gens qui se battent en politique
qui sont des gens motivés militants
sincères ça gâche tout en fait donc il
est gâché en politique il est gâché en
influenceur parce que s'ils sont rôle de
faire des vidéos comme ça que vous
garantir qu'il est gâche en influenceur
ça c'est comme le petit qui avait fait
les trucs dans les églises qui veulent
exister et qui sont prêts à faire
n'importe quoi pour exister sauf que ça
marchera pas réveillez-vous vous ne
serez jamais des influenceurs vous n'y
arriverez pas ils rêvent de rentrer dans
un monde mais en fait ça ne marchera pas
et encore pire aujourd'hui ou le monde
de l'influence est en train de changer
et veut des gens encore plus sincères
encore plus vrai parce qu'il y en a
beaucoup il y en a beaucoup plus
qu'avant c'est pas possible en fait on a
une vidéo en fait Tanguy David il a
essayé de se rendre chez les Le Pen
enfin bon et même si Le Pen
il s'est défendu ensuite sur les réseaux
sociaux en disant que il avait pas
réservé sa présence d'où ça donne entré
lors du betting de berline Le Pen mais
ce gamin je le croyais sérieux dans sa
démarche on a tous cru au début
des précédentes vidéos franchement
effectivement ça décrédibilise on peut
se dire il a de l'autodérision mais pas
du tout le pauvre
de son portrait avec un tableau d'Éric
Zemmour chez lui là il crache sur eximon
parce que la vidéo se moque d'Éric
Zemmour effectivement ces agressions
qu'elles soient avérées ou pas il les
mettait en scène dans un live sur
Instagram en disant aux gens rejoignez
le live pendant qu'il se faisait
agresser tout ça n'a aucun sens et il
n'est là que pour faire du buzz gens qui
sont pas encadrés en fait qui sont prêts
à faire n'importe quoi il y a pas
d'encadrement il y a pas il y a pas de
personne qui les conseillent et qui leur
disent arrête quoi
quand même oui bien sûr mais c'est ce
que j'ai dit qu'elle soit avéré ou pas
et on est quand même dans une culture du
live de l'intérêt sur les réseaux
sociaux et je trouve que pardon quand on
se fait agresser faire un live sur
Instagram en disant les amis rejoignez
le live ça pose quand même des questions
éventuellement live voilà évidemment
c'est un problème
moi je trouve qu'il y a une seule chose
à sauver de toute la séquence que l'on
Java c'est le petit costume rose poudré
que merci
on va on va vous le retrouver ce que
c'est vous l'offrir ça me fera plaisir
voilà parce que la date de Cyril